la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation et en a
t'il en séance je n'en vois point il est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
ja forme le c'est là qu'une candidature
pour siéger au sein de la commission des
lois a été publié elle sera ratifiée si
la présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement notre ordre du jour
appelle une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat en application de
l'article 50-1 de la constitution mes
chers collègues pour le respect des
règles sanitaires je vous rappelle qu'il
convient de laisser un siège vide entre
deux sièges ou occupés ou à défaut de
porter un masque si ça n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas qu'une formule rituelle
je pense qu'il faut qu'on y soit
attentif je rappelle également ce qui
n'était pas tout à fait le cas hier que
les sorties de la salle des séances
devront s'effectuer par les portiers tué
au pourtour de l'hémicycle et pour le
gouvernement parle de vent et en
seulement le premier ministre parmi nous
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
je vais donner la parole au premier
ministre monsieur jean castex
le premier ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président du sénat b dames
et messieurs des sénateurs permettez-moi
d'abord de vous dire l'immense honneur
et la grande émotion que je ressens au
moment de m'exprimer devant la haute
assemblée que vous formez si j'ai tenu à
présenter la politique de mon
gouvernement devant le sénat c'est avant
tout pour marquer mon attachement
personnel peut-être familiale au
bicamérisme et à l' équilibre
démocratique qu'il permet de garantir je
veux devant vous comme hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
témoigner de mon profond attachement à
notre système représentatif
je m'adresse à vous ce matin vous le
savez dans un moment très particulier
pour notre pays
mesurant pleinement la gravité du
contexte national européen international
dans lequel j'ai accédé à cette haute
responsabilité
je mesure que je dirige un gouvernement
de crise et donc un gouvernement de
combat nommé messieurs les sénateurs
l'actualité nous conduit à rappeler que
la crise c'est encore et toujours la
crise sanitaire
je voudrais préciser au sénat les
intentions du gouvernement dans la
période actuelle marquée vous le savez à
la fois par une forte activité de
l'épidémie dans certaines parties du
monde et par une situation nationale qui
demeure au contraire plutôt
favorablement orientées même si
certaines situations localiser appelle à
la plus grande vigilance
telle la guyane où j'ai d'ailleurs tenu
à me rendre dès ma prise de fonction en
conséquence et dans cette situation les
dispositions que je vais prendre
annoncées par le chef de l'état ne vise
pas tant à répondre ici en métropole à
une situation d'urgence mais plutôt à
nous inscrire dans une logique
préventive
nous allons à cet effet agir dans trois
directions
je veux d'abord vous dire que nous
sommes en train de renforcer nos
dispositifs de contrôle d'entrer sur le
territoire pour les personnes qui
peuvent souvent être des ressortissants
français pour ça que des mesures
d'interdiction absolue sont difficiles à
envisager en provenance de tous les pays
où la circulation virale est plus forte
l'idéal l'idéal serait et c'est ce qui
est d'ailleurs envisagé que les
contrôles sanitaires puisse être
réalisée dans les pays de départ mais
nous devons être pragmatiques et sans
certitude absolue que cela soit possible
j'ai décidé que nous allions amplifier
des mesures de contrôle sanitaire à
l'arrivée sur le territoire national
dans les ports et les aéroports
nous entendons également développer
encore les tests de dépistage ceux ci
sont en constante augmentation et le
point le plus positif c'est que leur
résultat quand ils sont pratiqués
demeurent très largement favorable
et en tout cas les tests positifs sont
très nettement inférieur à ce que aux
modélisations qui avait été réalisée au
mois de mai ce qui témoigne sans doute
de l'efficacité de la politique conduite
mais le nombre de tests demeure
insuffisant et s'est expliquée par la
considération précédente
non je le dis au sénat que nous
manquions d'équipement et de personnel
pour les réaliser notamment depuis que
les techniciens de laboratoire ont été
autorisés à effectuer les prélèvements
mais tout simplement parce que nos
concitoyens ne se fonde pas suffisamment
testés ils sont ils sensibles à
l'ambiance générale où l'on dit où l'on
dit que l'épidémie est maîtrisé ce
qu'est le cas il faut donc lever tous
les obstacles y compris psychologique
qui explique cette situation
le président de la république a ainsi
annoncé la fin des prescriptions
médicales obligatoires pour se faire
tester et j'ai par ailleurs demandait ce
que nous accélérions l'évaluation de la
fiabilité scientifique des tests
salivaires beaucoup plus simple à
réaliser beaucoup moins douloureux et il
nous faudra par ailleurs continuer à
intensifier les actions proactives
invitant des habitants de certaines
communes de certains quartiers à
réaliser des tests ce que nous avons
déjà commencé depuis plusieurs semaines
à faire notamment en ile de france avec
une efficacité certaine
enfin le port du masque constitue avec
le respect des gestes dits barrière une
mesure de prévention et de protection
efficace
j'ai donc proposé que l'obligation de le
porter soit renforcée dans tous les
établissements recevant du public
clo en particulier ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui les commerces
cela nécessite un décret alors que dans
les locaux dits professionnels
cela suppose une évolution des
protocoles sanitaires régissant les
activités concernées nous envisagions
une entrée en vigueur de ces
dispositions le premier route parce
qu'encore une fois nous agissons dans
une logique préventive et pas sous
l'empiré de l'urgence j'ai entendu et
compris que cette échéance apparaissait
tardive ou susciter quelques
interrogations
le décret entrera donc en vigueur la
semaine prochaine j'ai demandé j'ai
demandé par ailleurs aux ministres
chargés de la santé de l'éducation
nationale l'enseignement supérieur de
donner très rapidement des indications
précises aux familles au corps
enseignant sur les conditions dans
lesquelles se déroulera la rentrée de
septembre dans les établissements
d'enseignement l'homme et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur président dans la
gestion de cette crise les élus ont été
remarquables d'implication et de
dévouement a commencé à commencer par
les maires qui ont comme toujours été
combattants de la première ligne et de
la première charge et vous le savez par
le précédent gouvernement de préparer le
des consignes mans j'avais alors
recommandé que le couple maires préfets
de département soit placée au coeur du
dispositif
ce qui fut fait j'avais également
suggéré
et que l'état soutienne les
collectivités locales dans leur
politique d'acquisition de masques pour
conforter et démultiplier nos actions ce
qui a également était décidée et au delà
de la crise sanitaire
voilà bien un enseignement structurel
qu'il nous faudra tirer ensemble pour la
conduite de l'action publique
au delà de la crise sanitaire nous
sommes en effet vous le savez frappé par
une crise économique et sociale sans
précédent depuis plusieurs mois cette
crise frappe notre économie très
durement
elle accentue encore j'y reviendrai la
vulnérabilité des plus démunis etc
risquent de creuser les inégalités y
compris la fait face à la maladie elle
dégrade fortement nos finances publiques
nous finances sociales venant fragilité
notre modèle
elle nous rappelle également l'ampleur
du défi écologique
il est des heures mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ou l'ensemble des forces
vives d'un pays doivent plus que jamais
se rassemblent et ma conviction est que
nous sommes précisément dans un tel
moment
l'esprit de dialogue
la volonté de dépasser des postures et
les clivages qui m'anime sens je le sais
des principes qui vous sont chers à ce
titre d'ailleurs les français eux mêmes
nous en donner l'exemple ils ont été
solidaires et résilient face à la crise
sanitaire
nous devons prendre collectivement la
mesure d'un situation
si nous ne réagissons pas elle pourrait
accentuer les fractures qui traverse
notre pays est menacé
notre unité déjà bien mise à mal
notamment les fractures territoriales
prendre à bras le corps cette crise
protéger les français reconstruire notre
économie et au delà conforter notre
pacte républicain
tels sont les défis qui se présentent
devant moi et devant le gouvernement que
je conduis mon discours de politique
générale hier devant l'assemblée a été
aussi lue devant vous par monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères je ne reviendrai donc pas
dans le détail de l'ensemble des mesures
que j'ai évoqués vous l'avez compris ma
conviction mais que pour réussir nous
devons changer nos façons de faire
il faut dire et affirmer que l'état un
rôle majeur mais qu'il ne peut qu il ne
pourra agir seul il devra fédérer les
bonnes volontés mobiliser toutes les
énergies et faire confiance
faire confiance à tous ses partenaires à
commencer par les collectivités que vous
représentez permettez-moi de vars la
chambre des territoires de me
revendiquer comme un premier ministre
des territoires les territoires et de la
vie quotidienne des gens aujourd'hui je
veux donc évoquer avec vous les
priorités que dans ce cadre
dans ce contexte mon gouvernera mon
gouvernement portera dans les deux
prochaines années mais j'entends tout
autant vous expliquer la manière dont
j'entends m'engager dans la mise en
oeuvre concrète de ces orientations
car l'exercice de la responsabilité
politique ne peut s'arrêter aux
intentions si louable et ambitieuse soit
elle rien ne vaut 100 l'obsession du
résultat et de l'impact sur la vie de
nos concitoyens
j'ai rappelé hier cette phrase célèbre
l'intendance suivra
non l'intendance ne suit pas en tout cas
pas toujours et même de moins en moins
alors même que cela devrait être la
priorité
la mise en oeuvre l'exécution les
conditions de réalisation doivent temps
très clairement dans le champ de la
politique et ne plus être considérés
comme de simples sujets triviaux et
technique
je vous concède bien volontiers qu'il
s'agit là d'un choc culturel dans un
pays où depuis le siècle des lumières le
débat d'idées l'invocation des grands
principes le maniement des concepts
monopolisent le débat public car c'est
vous le savez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est sur l'exécution que nos
concitoyens nous attendent et sont
fondés à nous juger
c'est surtout par l'exécution par la
charge de la preuve que se reconstruire
à la confiance dans les responsables
publics ont tant besoin et qui vous le
savez comme moi c'est fortement altérée
pour réussir nous ne pouvons donc pas
nous contenter de fixer un cadre
juridique au niveau national
nous devons nous impliquer dans le
déploiement dans la mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques et où cela dans les
territoires dans les territoires pour
les adapter à la vie des gens dans nos
régions nos départements nos cantons nos
communes nos quartiers et pour cela il
faut faire confiance aux territoires la
france des territoires c'est la france
de la proximité à laquelle nous devons
impérativement faire confiance car c'est
elle qui détient en large par les
leviers du sursaut collectif libérer les
territoires c'est libérer des énergies
nous devons réarmer nos territoires nous
devons investir dans nos territoires
nous devons nous appuyer sur nos
territoires
la république territoriales c'est
l'unité dans la diversité
je compte sur vous durant les six jours
qu'il nous reste pour m'aider dans un
esprit de concorde
parce que si la défiance progresse
encore
elle nous emportera tous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la bataille de l'emploi sera la première
priorité pour 2020 vous savez que nous
prévoyons à ce jour une récession de 11%
soit la récession la plus sévère depuis
que les comptes nationaux ont été clé
derrière et données comptables des
drames humains des territoires meurtri
tout cela nous devons le prévoir
l'accompagner le soulager et nous devons
aller plus loin c'est à dire se saisir
de cette situation pour reconvertir
notre économie notre travailleurs et nos
salariés pour les rendre plus fort plus
compétitif est davantage orientée
vers une croissance durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement
tel est l'objectif premier j'allais dire
unique central de notre politique et du
plan de relance de l'économie que j'ai
présenté hier à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai entendu à l'occasion de ce débat
que nous n'irions pas assez vite
pas assez fort pour soutenir l'économie
et lutter contre la dégradation de
l'emploi
nous avons en effet pour objectif je
vous le confirme de présenter notre
ambitieux plan de relance à la fin du
mois d'août après une phase de
concertation
l'explication de ce calendrier est
simple ce plan constituera l'étape
suivante d'un processus de soutien à
l'activité
caractérisé par l'ampleur et la
précocité des mesures prises par la
france sous l'égide de mon prédécesseur
vous en connaissez les vecteurs le
chômage partiel les prêts garantis par
l'état et le fonds de solidarité qui ont
représenté un effort global et massif de
près de 500 milliards d'euros
cela a permis à notre économie de ne pas
s'effondrer
et si l'on regarde autour de nous cette
politique a été la plus ambitieuse de
tous les pays européens et les résultats
à nantes était une immense à lui et à
commencer par le peuple français
très vite et très tôt nous avons
également mis en place des plans
sectoriels très ambitieux dans le
tourisme l'aéronautique l'automobile la
culture le commerce le btp les nouvelles
technologies
tout cela mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs aient voulu vérifierez
car tel est votre rôle a porté ses
fruits les derniers chiffres publiés par
l'insee et la banque de france semble
indiquer une reprise plus rapide que
prévu grâce à ces mesures en particulier
la consommation des ménages affiche une
reprise solide depuis la fin du
confinement
nous n'excluons pas n'avons pas les
chiffres définitifs qu'au moins de juin
elle soit proche de son niveau normal
avec un effet de rattrapage marqué pour
les biens d'équipement
grâce au plan automobile que j'évoquais
les imitent les immatriculations de
véhicules neufs
on retrouvait dès juin leur niveau de
février elles ont dépassé de prendre
pour cent leur niveau de février pour
les ventes aux particuliers
donc nous sommes dans la continuité de
ce qui a été fait tous ne commence pas
avec le plan de relance qui va donc
constituer une étape supplémentaire est
nouvelle mais avec une philosophie
inchangé protéger les français
reconstruire et moderniser la france en
particulier en prolongeant les
dispositifs d'activité partielle
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
préserver l'emploi et les salaires dans
les entreprises les plus impactés par la
crise j'ai dit je répète nous en
parlerons demain avec les partenaires
sociaux que le gouvernement a pris acte
du contexte économique
j'allais dire nouveau bouleversé en
décidant d'aménager
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
élaboré dans un contexte bonne réforme
mais nécessairement affectée par le
contexte nouveau
je les dis aussi la première urgence
parce qu'ils vont être comme toujours
les premiers touchés par la crise
économique ce sont les jeunes sont les
jeunes 700 800 migrants arrivés sur le
marché du travail c'est une force de
notre pays on fait des comparaisons en
particulier avec l'allemagne il n'a non
pas autant il serait très heureux d'en
avoir autant c'est pas le cas chez nous
oui mais ça nous oblige beaucoup ont vu
leurs études arrêtées pendant le
confinement leur stage interrompu leur
vie sociale profondément perturbés il
n'est pas possible que la nation accepte
que le chômage constitue le seul horizon
pour ces centaines de milliers de jeunes
en france
il n'est pas question de laisser
s'installer l'idée d'une génération
sacrifiée à cause de cette crise et pour
cela nous allons engager des mesures
fortes
donc je vous dis tout de suite puisque
elles seront au menu de la conférence
que nous tiendrons demain avec les
partenaires sociaux qu'elles sont encore
susceptibles de s'améliorer
je le dis à la représentation nationale
l'état a la volonté de mettre en place
une très forte baisse du coût du travail
pour faciliter l'embauché des jeunes
nous allons parallèlement développer
massivement dans des proportions qui
n'ont jamais été atteinte
les dispositifs d'insertion en
particulier
vis-à-vis des jeunes les plus en
difficulté le service civique au service
de l'engagement des jeunes et de leur
insertion sera considérablement
renforcée ce sera au passage aussi l'une
des manières de soutenir nos
associations et leurs 20 millions de
bénévoles qui personne ne l'oublient
constitue aussi un atout majeur pour
renforcer la cohésion sociale et de lien
social dans notre pays
à l'université la crise a aussi agi
comme révélateur des difficultés que
rencontrent encore de trop nombreux
étudiants
nous avons décidé de geler les droits
d'inscription et nous avons décidé de
porter à 1 euro le prix des repas dans
les restaurants universitaires pour les
étudiants boursiers
mesdames et messieurs pour conforter
notre action et notre cohésion face à la
crise il nous faut aussi consolider
notre modèle social
car la crise vient l'impact est
fortement
il appelle aujourd'hui de notre part des
interventions fortes et nouvelles pour
améliorer son fonctionnement est mieux
en garantir les équilibres dans la durée
je pense d'abord évidemment évidemment à
notre système de santé et qui a
finalement démontré sa robustesse cours
des derniers mois dans un contexte de
tension extrême dont nous devons bien
reconnaître qu'il préexistait à la crise
du covin cette situation appelez une
réponse d'envergure une réponse urgente
c'est l'objet du ségur de la santé que
mon prédécesseur a lancé en mai dernier
et qui va s'achever dans les prochains
jours une négociation a été conduite
avec l'ensemble des acteurs et un accord
majoritaire majoritaire a été vous le
savez un accord historique conclu lundi
dernier cet accord c'est d'abord un
accord une marque un témoignage au nom
de la nation tout entière de
reconnaissance à l'endroit de ses
personnels de reconnaissance une mise à
niveau de leur rémunération est un
investissement massif pour la
transformer et la moderniser 8 milliards
d'euros consacrés à la revalorisation
des salaires
c'est ce qui était prévu et je les dis
ici même la semaine dernière à la
création d'emplois qu'il n'était pas
envisagé dans le projet initial
le plan de relance le plan de relance
prévoir à 6 milliards dédiés à
l'investissement en ville et à l'hôpital
immobilier mais également dans le champ
de la e-santé 13 milliards de reprise de
dette hospitalière pour permettre aux
établissements de retrouver de l'oxygène
et donc une capacité à investir à
l'hôpital comme ailleurs
l'investissement
vous le savez bien constitue l'un des
leviers essentiels de la relance
économique
mais au delà de ses moyens financiers
il faut améliorer le fonctionnement
quotidien des structures en leur donnant
davantage souplesse en leur permettant
de déroger à certains cadres nationaux
sur des sujets de gouvernance internes
d'organisation et de modalités de temps
de travail en favorisant davantage les
logiques de décloisonnement entre ville
et hôpital à l'échelle des territoires
en permettant enfin aux collectivités
d'être davantage partie prenante des
stratégies d'investissement et
d'organisation des soins tant au niveau
des agences régionales de santé que des
établissements eux mêmes
je souhaite à cet effet que les régions
les départements et les
intercommunalités puis se prendre une
part plus grande dans la gestion de
notre système de santé qu'elle puisse si
elles le souhaitent s'associer aux
investissements que nous allons y
décider cela va se faire dans un cadre
clair sur la base de contrats
territoriaux conclu avec l'état et les
structures de soins avec je le répète
une participation accrue des élus à la
gouvernance de ce système
je n'ignore pas que l'autre question
majeure que nous posent nos concitoyens
dans le domaine de la santé
c'est la difficulté qu'ils rencontrent
pour accéder à un médecin généraliste ou
spécialiste notamment en ville nous
savons tous ici la difficulté du sujet
il faut dix ans pour former de nouveaux
médecins et la tension va toucher et
touchent déjà dans les prochaines années
la plupart des territoires
nous devons agir de manière pragmatique
pour être
efficace à court terme la seule solution
en tout cas l'une des principale est de
permettre aux médecins en exercice de
pouvoir travailler dans de meilleures
conditions
dans des organisations plus collective
en favorisant plus de délégations de
tâches en les dotant d'assistant
médicaux en les allégeant des trop
nombreuses charges administratives qui
leur prend du temps l'autre priorité
sera de recourir davantage à la
télémédecine dont j'ai pu constater dans
mon territoire qu'elle a connu à la
faveur de la crise du coc vide un essor
tout à fait spectaculaire je vous avoue
presque inattendu dans ces proportions
et dont il nous appartient maintenant de
consolider et de sécuriser la place
dans les pratiques médicales
nous ne retrouverons pas l'unité ça une
attention accrue aux plus vulnérables
d'entre nous ils ont été davantage
touchées par la crise sanitaire
ils seront également avec les jeunes les
plus fortement affectée par la crise
économique a commencé d'ailleurs par les
personnes en situation de handicap et
nous réunirons une conférence nationale
du handicap consacré à ces sujets
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
consolider notre modèle de protection
sociale c'est aussi prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer sa pérennité en
matière de retraite
la crise nous invite plus que jamais à
poursuivre nos objectifs faire un
système plus juste et plus équitable
notamment pour les femmes et pour les
travailleurs modestes passant par la
création d'un régime universel
je les dis et je le répète cela implique
clairement à mes yeux la disparition à
terme des régimes spéciaux tout en
prenant comme nous avions commencé de le
faire dans la réforme de 2008 tout en
prenant pleinement en considération la
situation des bénéficiaires actuels de
ces régimes je suis donc déterminé à ce
que cette réforme parce que c'est
l'intérêt du pays aille à son terme
d'ici la fin de cette législature
mais je pense dans le même temps que
nous devons entendre les inquiétudes et
les incompréhensions qui se sont exprimé
chez nos concitoyens
s'agissant de certaines des modalités du
projet dont le parlement a été saisie je
proposerai donc aux partenaires sociaux
comme aux parlementaires que sur les
bases que je viens d'indiquer la
concertation reprennent rapidement afin
d'améliorer le contenu comme la
lisibilité de cette réforme nécessaire
en la distinguant très clairement de
tout enjeu d'ajustement paramétrique
pour employer des formules
technocratique des régimes existants
je suis en effet convaincu qu'une telle
réforme qui nous engagera pour des
décennies nécessite de prendre le temps
nécessaire pour essayer de trouver les
meilleurs point d'équilibré
en ce sens elle s'inscrit pour moi
dans la première phase de réforme des
régimes spéciaux décidé en 2007
enfin au delà du sujet de la retraite
nous devons aussi répondre à la question
du grand âge et de la dépendance
ce sentier si souvent annoncé
si longtemps attendu sur lequel le sénat
a déjà apporté de nombreuses
contributions monsieur le président doit
aboutir à un projet de loi dont vous
serez saisie au premier semestre de
l'année prochaine
je demanderai également demain aux
partenaires sociaux de se saisir avec
l'état des questions de l'equilibre de
l'ensemble les régimes de protection
sociale profondément impactés par la
crise l'unité suppose aussi que l'état
demeure le garant de l'ordre républicain
l'état doit être le même pour tous
nous ne tolèrerons aucune zone de
non-droit à tous nos concitoyens je veux
affirmer notre totale détermination à
assurer leur sécurité
je le disais hier à l'assemblée je le
répète devant vous nous ne montrerons
aucune faiblesse contre tous ceux qui
s'en prennent à l'ordre public tente de
fracturer le pays entre communautés et
portent atteinte aux valeurs cardinales
de la laïcité à nos policiers et
gendarmes
je souhaite exprimer au nom de la nation
mon profond respect et ma gratitude
il incarne l'ordre républicain et
exercent leurs missions dans des
conditions parfois extrêmement délicate
je veillerai avec monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur à ce qu'il puisse obtenir
les moyens matériels et humains
nécessaires pour conduire leur mission à
ce qu'il puisse être là où ils sont
attendus
sur le terrain à les déchargeant au
maximum de tâches administratives
parfois chronophage je ne peux parler de
ce qui protège les français sans évoquer
le rôle fondamental de nos armées vous
le savez dans le combat contre les
ennemis de la liberté
elle porte haut les couleurs de la
france et je me plaisent à souligner que
c'est sous cette mandature qu'un effort
exceptionnel de la nation a été décidée
pour renforcer leur efficacité
[Musique]
mais je voudrais me permettre d'insister
particulièrement devant vous comme je
lai fait hier devant les députés plus
que jamais pour que l'ordre républicain
soit effectif pour que la sécurité de
nos concitoyens soit assurée il faut
bien sûr que les forces de police et de
gendarmerie trouve la reconnaissance et
les moyens dans l'accomplissement de
leur mission
mais il faut aussi et peut-être surtout
que les moyens d'action de la justice
soit renforcé pour la rendre plus
accessible plus compréhensible et plus
efficace cet historique et les
comparaisons internationales souvent
fait d'ailleurs par cette assemblée le
démontre l'état et nous sommes là au
coeur de ses prérogatives
il y a des choses je vous le disais tout
à l'heure qui doivent être et qui seront
mieux faites par d'autres mais la
justice c'est l'état et l'état c'est la
justice et l'état depuis de nombreuses
années ne donne pas à la justice c'est
moyenne d'intervention
il en résulte il en résulte
que l'action des forces de l'ordre se
trouvent parfois sans suite
il en résulte que des situation
d'impunité soit ressentie de manière
particulièrement inacceptable par nos
concitoyens par les élus de territoire
et par les maires au premier chef
vous avez voté une loi de programmation
et de réforme de la justice
j'entends en accélérer la mise en oeuvre
en réorientant par déploiement dès 2021
les moyens affectés au budget de ce
ministère en particulier pour rendre
plus rapides et effectives la réponse
judiciaire améliorer la politique des
peines garantir la dignité la
réinsertion des prisonniers moderniser
le fonctionnement des juridictions
on pourra à l'envi augmenter les moyens
de la police et de la gendarmerie
vous le savez tout dit et tout ici avec
vos expériences de terrain
si la réponse judiciaire ne suis pas il
ne se passera rien il faut donc aller au
coeur du dispositif
c'est le devoir de l'état c'est
l'intention de ce gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
renforcer la confiance c'est enfin
veiller à ce que la justice soit rendue
c'est un chantier auquel le garde des
sceaux est particulièrement attaché à ce
qu'elle soit rendue dans des conditions
d'écouté et de dialogue
les plus complètes oui mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs aucune forme de
violence ne peut être toléré la lutte
contre les violences conjugales sera
l'une des grandes priorités de la
politique pénale du gouvernement faire
régner leur rendre la justice
mais ce sont les valeurs car vidal de
l'état
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs parlant
du pacte républicain et de l'unité de la
nation
je vous dise je voudrais vous dire ma
conviction mon attachement profond à
l'école de la république fils
d'institutrice je sais ce que je dois à
la méritocratie républicaine
je veux d'ailleurs dire toute mon
admiration au corps enseignant depuis
trois ans une profonde refondation de
l'école a été engagée nous la
poursuivrons la poursuivrons là aussi en
tirant les enseignements de la crise et
en ciblant notre action sur les enfants
qui ont décroché durant le déconfinement
dès le début de l'année scolaire les
professeurs veilleront à identifier les
besoins de chaque élève
grâce à des évaluations nationales et
chaque famille qui en fera la demande
pourra bénéficier d'un programme
personnalisé de soutien scolaire pour sa
d'enfants au cours du premier trimestre
de l'année scolaire
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais achevé mon propos en vous
disant que mon gouvernement s'appuiera
sur les territoires pour conduire sa
politique c'est une question de respect
c'est surtout une question d'efficacité
laitages lady est le garant des
fonctions régaliennes qui c'est l'unité
de la nation
mais pour l'ensemble des grandes
transition écologique économique et
sociale les acteurs territoriaux doivent
être à la manoeuvre
l'état et les collectivités ont la
république en partage ils sont les
partenaires indispensables
de la réussite de nos politiques
publiques dès les premiers jours de ma
prise de fonction j'ai rencontré
l'ensemble des associations
représentatives de ces collectivités
et évidemment la relance économique que
nous allons engager sera le premier
terrain de mise en oeuvre de cette
mobilisation conjointe toutes les
collectivités y auront une part
essentielle nous devons rapidement
achever de régler avec elle les
questions liées aux conséquences de la
crise sur leurs finances et la question
de l'impact sur leurs ressources des
impôts de production qu'il faudra
alléger pour concourir à la reconquête
de notre souveraineté économique
l'objectif est en effet que les
collectivités puissent parce que c'est
dans leurs gènes investir forme et agir
de manière la plus massive possible
n'est en cohérence avec nous car nos
concitoyens ne nous pardonneraient pas
ne nous pardonneraient dans les
circonstances présentes ni dispersion ni
divisions stériles
elles le seront monsieur le président
jammeh de mon fait
et je sais que le sénat partage
pleinement cette vision des choses
le plan de relance prévoit d'ailleurs de
soutenir les interventions des
collectivités locales dans leurs champs
de compétences et nous devons
impérativement redonner du sens et
surtout de la chaire au futur contrat de
plats et de territoire je voudrais
insister auprès de vous sur deux
chantiers majeurs qui illustreront cet
engagement partagé
d'abord celui de la formation
professionnelle
que les circonstances présentes vont je
les dis fortement mobilisés le plan de
relance parce nous en sommes tous
d'accord par un effort accru en matière
de formation professionnelle
l'enjeu ici est bien sûr de permettre à
ceux de nos concitoyens qui perdent leur
emploi dans retrouver un au plus vite et
nous investirons pour cela un milliard
et demi d'euros supplémentaires
nous nous fixons un objectif de 200
mille places supplémentaires qui
pourront être ouvertes en 2021 au
bénéfice des jeunes et des demandeurs
d'emploi qui peut imaginer que nous
pourrions construire ce plan sans le
concours des régions compétentes au
premier chef en la matière nous devons
également poursuivre l'effort de
reconquête industrielle à travers le
programme territoire d'industrie
largement décliné par les régions autres
prix y est essentielle celle de la
transition écologique madame la ministre
qui réussira d'autant mieux qu'elle
reposera sur une mise en oeuvre
partagez et territorialisée le plan de
relance le plan de relance déploiera au
moins un tiers de ces crédits à
destination de la transition écologique
nous allons d'abord investir dans le
bâtiment et les transports
nous investirons dans les technologies
vertes de demain comme l'hydrogène pour
mieux recyclé et moins gaspiller
accélérer la transition écologique c'est
aussi investir en faveur d'une offre
d'alimentation saine et durable pour que
tous les français
même les plus fragiles et accède en
lamentations de qualité
nous allons également ensemble protéger
les terres agricoles
j'ai annoncé hier à l'assemblée
nationale notre volonté de décréter un
moratoire pour tout projet nouveau
d'installation de centres commerciaux
dans les zones périurbaines et nous
définirons en concertation avec vous et
toutes les parties prenantes de
nouvelles règles d'autorisation
d'exploitation commerciale surtout pour
réussir cette reconstruction
nous allons donner davantage de liberté
aux territoires et aux collectivités
je tiens à vous remercier monsieur le
président cher gérard larcher pour les
50 propositions du sénat pour une
nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation et je salue les deux
rapporteurs messieurs philippe bas et
jean marie bockel
pour celles et ceux qui connaissent ici
ma conception des choses ne peuvent pas
douter que ces propositions feront de ma
part l'objet d'un examen très attentif
et très bienveillant dès aujourd'hui dès
aujourd'hui madame la ministre des
collectivités et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
jacqueline gourault reprend les
nombreuses concertations lancées en
janvier dans le cadre du futur projet de
loi dit 3d pour décentralisation
déconcentration différenciation et dans
ce cadre évidemment tous les échelons de
collectivités et les associations d'élus
seront et continueront d'être
étroitement associés tout ceci tout ce
travail de concertation aboutira à une
prochaine conférence nationale des
territoires où nous annoncerons
clairement nos intentions premières
étapes
première étape nous allons consacre
consacrer le droit à la différenciation
dans une loi organique
concrètement développer la
différenciation s'est d'abord faciliter
l'expérimentation
oui des réponses différentes doivent
être apportées à des situations
différentes
dans notre pays construit depuis plus de
deux siècles sur l'uniformisation
c'est une révolution dès la fin de ce
mois un projet de loi organique sera
présenté en conseil des ministres et
viendra donner un nouveau cadre aux
expérimentations menées par les
collectivités locales pour qu'elles
ouvrent la voie à une différenciation
durable un autre projet de loi viendra
consacrer est donnée de l'effectivité à
ces trois principes différenciation
décentralisation
des concentrations donner plus de
liberté aux collectivités c'est aussi
faire évoluer profondément
l'organisation interne de l'état une
nécessité également pour rendre l'état
plus proche des concitoyens
je le dis pour l'avoir vécu l'état c'est
trop éloignée on a commencé à favoriser
des temps régionales sans doute pour des
soucis d'économie mais quand les régions
sont devenus ensuite dimas région cette
intention sans doute louable s'est
retourné contre la proximité et
l'efficacité des politiques de l'état
[Applaudissements]
nous rendrons rapidement plus cohérente
efficace l'organisation de l'état en
particulier au niveau du département
les moyens de l'état seront confortées
dans leur action quotidienne et ce dès
le projet de loi de finances pour 2021
puisque je veillerai à ce que toutes les
créations d'emplois pas forcément des
créations nettes d'emplois mais il faut
bien recruté pour remplacer les gens qui
partent à la retraite etc
on va donc créer des emplois eh bien je
veillerai que sauf exception justifiée
elle les interviennent tout au bénéfice
de l'échelon départemental de l'état et
plus en administration centrale
c'est une révolution dont je vous prie
de mesure et qu'elle va mon casio n'ait
beaucoup de soucis
[Applaudissements]
j'ajoute mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qu'il nous faudra aussi
profité de la crise vous me pardonnerez
cette expression non seulement pour
pérenniser les dispositifs de
dérogations et de simplification
administrative qui ont été adopté par
ordonnance à la faveur de la crise
sanitaire
la crise économique je les dis sera au
moins aussi fortes dans son ampleur
elle va donc justifiée elle va donc
justifier que nous allions encore plus
loin encore plus fort dans les démarches
de simplification qu'il s'agisse du
droit de la commande publique des
autorisations et de tous les dispositifs
qui vous le savez vous qu est ancrée
dans les territoires retardent et
contrarie sans cesse la réalisation
d'investissements indispensables et je
sais monsieur le président que le sénat
sera une mine de propositions en la
matière mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je voudrais également vous dire notre
volonté de renforcer l' équilibre des
territoires
nous voulons en effet dans le cadre de
notre agenda rural amplifier les actions
en direction de la ruralité
je souhaite ici vous faire partagé ma
conviction que la priorité des priorités
c'est de trouver ou de retrouver le
chemin d'un développement économique du
monde rural
car en réalité si les services publics
qui ont fermé au cours des dernières
années
c'est parce que la population il ya
diminué et si la population il ya
diminué c'est d'abord parce que
l'économie et l'emploi dans notre pays
se concentre désormais dans les très
grandes agglomérations dans les très
grandes agglomérations il faut donc il
faut donc revitalisée par l'économie le
service public suivra mais il ne faut
pas inverser l'ordre des facteurs nos
territoires ruraux est d'abord et il
faut les embarquer dans la révolution
numérique
il est donc vital d'investir dans une
politique de réseau et de maillage
d'abord en accélérant la couverture de
tout le territoire en très haut débit
pour faciliter notamment le télétravail
la télémédecine d'où les usagers au
numérique les raisons c'est aussi la
conservation des lignes ferroviaires
c'est aussi je le dis devant le sénat
peut-être réinvestir dans les routes
parce que à certains endroits ce sont
les seules voies pour désenclaver les
territoires
cela rejoint les débats que nous aurons
sur la décentralisation
doit-on conserver des routes nationales
que l'état a bien du mal
entretenir et qu'il ne développe plus
peut-on c'est une question que je pose
au sénat puisqu'il l'a lui même soulevé
renvoyé pour autant cette responsabilité
au département n'est-il pas temps de
conforter des régions dans leur rôle de
responsable de toutes les mobilités en
envisageant des routes structurantes
d'intérêt
régionales je soumets je soumets ses
réflexions à la sagacité du sénat et
puisque je parle de réseau et je parle
de mobilité
je voulais vous dire que le plan de
relance portera une attention
particulière aux pistes cyclables on m'a
manqué quand j'ai dit ça on a dit il
parle d'un gadget
pas du tout mesdames et messieurs center
pas du tout pas du tout le vélo c'est
bon pour l'environnement
c'est bon pour la santé et nous sommes à
une révolution c'est le vélo électrique
il va multiplier les usages il va
multiplier les usages il va raccourcir
les distances oui oui mesdames et
messieurs oui mesdames et messieurs ne
riez pas
ne riez pas dans dix ans dans dix ans on
pourra si on fait un réseau de pistes
cyclables sécurisées on pourra aller de
prades à perpignan un vélo pour aller
travailler
oui ça c'est concret ça c'est concret et
c'est ce qui va se passer et je vous le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
les jeunes générations attendent cela
oui tout ceci tout ceci vous paraît
secondaire
tout ceci vous paraît secondaire
peut-être c'est un sujet essentiel c'est
aussi un sujet concret les gens vont
comprendre cela les gens vont comprendre
cela et c'est une bonne façon de faire
de l'écologie et du développement
durable à la portée de tous et de toutes
je savais que ce sujet verrait beaucoup
à l'entente semblait ce président
robin ercis nous poursuivrons également
je reviens à la ruralité mais je n'étais
jamais sorti le déploiement du programme
action car de vide qui s'adresse déjà
cher jacqueline à 234 villes de petite
taille ou de taille intermédiaire et
surtout nous déploierons fortement là
c'est encore la strate au dessous
je la connais bien le programme dix
petites villes de demain avec un
objectif gouvernemental claire 1000
villes concernées en plus partout sur le
territoire
il s'agit de faire de toutes nos villes
petites et moyennes
des lieux plus attractif exemplaire doté
de services essentiels et où il fait bon
vivre
de la même façon j'ai fixé à mon
gouvernement des objectifs précis et
quantifiés
s'agissant du plan de rénovation urbaine
nous sommes ici dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville il y à 450
quartiers qui sont concernés là aussi
des très belles intentions des objectifs
louables restaurer la république dans
ces quartiers permettre l'émancipation
de ses habitants mais une fois encore
tout est dans l'art d'exécution 450
quartiers concernés les moyens seront
dans le plan de relance
ce sont des dépenses d'investissement
ce sont des dépenses d'investissement ce
ne sont pas des dépenses de
fonctionnement 450 quartiers concernés
disait ge
mais finalement très peu ayant fait
l'objet d'une mise en oeuvre effective
est plutôt que d'annoncer aujourd'hui au
sénat on va passer de 450 à 600 à 800
est ce que vous voulez veillon plus tôt
pour assurer notre crédibilité
collective qu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine dans au moins trois cents
d'entre eux les choses
et concrètement bouger mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la république ne
serait rien sans les territoires qui la
composent
dans leur diversité et leur insondable
richesse cette diversité croyez moi je
la connais bien
fils du gers
mais pour territoire rural élus dans les
pyrénées-orientales comme territoires
éloignés
je suis surtout un enfant de la
république que je m'efforce de servir
avec passion et je suis persuadé que
cette diversité de la france exprimait
avec admiration
fernand braudel au soir de sa vie est
plus que jamais un chemin d'espérance
c'est en tout cas le sens de l'action
que j'entends porter à la tête du
gouvernement que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger sous l'autorité du président de
la république
c'est le sens de l'engagement qui est le
mien depuis de nombreuses années et que
j'ai porté dans les différentes
responsabilités publiques et les mandats
démocratique que j'ai eu l'honneur
d'exercer au service de nos concitoyens
c'est surtout le sens de la mobilisation
collective qui doit être la nôtre dans
les circonstances très difficiles que
notre pays traverse
c'est le sens de l'invitation que
j'adresse à toutes les forces
démocratiques à toutes les forces vives
à tous les territoires de s'unir de
s'unir pour agir de s'unir pour réussir
ensemble pour notre pays parce que nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes
je vais donner la parole tout d'abord au
président philippe adnot soulignant il
m'a t-il dit que c'était son dernier
discours comme sénateur ils siègent
parmi nos depuis 1989 et je lui exprime
ma gratitude comme animateur des
sénateurs donne aux screen merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues je voudrais monsieur le
premier ministre vous féliciter pour
votre nomination et vous souhaiter bonne
chance vous féliciter d'avoir été choisi
et d'avoir accepté une tâche
particulièrement difficile
bonne chance car notre pays va être
confronté à une situation inédite
l'argent a coulé à flots et pourtant
notre économie et l'emploi risque d'être
au coeur d'une situation explosive
je n'ai que cinq minutes monsieur le
premier ministre je devais donc pas
abordés